merci d'être avec nous avec les
nostalgique nous accompagner pendant
cette première devenir vous êtes allés
du Val-d'Oise en du groupe les
républicains on va parler dans quelques
instants de l'audition que vous avez
faite hier d'Éric Dupond-Moretti sur les
revenons du jet mais d'un beau d'abord
un mot sur Eric Dupond-Moretti le garde
des sceaux qui est renvoyé devant la
Cour de Justice de la République c'est
une première est-ce qu'il est un Miss
fragilisé aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il peut
se maintenir à son poste bon moi j'ai
pas dit ce qui est bien il s'est pas
bien dans ce domaine le président ce qui
pose problème c'est
c'est ce que dit le président de la
République c'est le premier mandat il a
fait partir du gouvernement un certain
nombre de féministres qui n'étaient pas
dans cette situation aussi compliquée là
aujourd'hui il souhaite conserver
monsieur Dupont-Moretti il faudra qu'il
en assume les conséquences pour les mois
qui viennent voilà je pense que c'est le
choix du président de l'avoir conservé
il appartiendra au président d'assumer
ou moi je me mêle pas des affaires du
président de la République aujourd'hui
il a fait ce choix bon je vais pas
rentrer dans cette guéguerre
politicienne bon c'est Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti qui a été maintenu de
garder sceaux et bien c'est Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti avec lequel on échangera
sur les sujets de la justice et vous
avez déjà échangé hier sur un autre
sujet un vous l'avez auditionné on va en
parler auditionner sur les revenantes du
Jihad on va voir les temps forts de
cette audition avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour
additionner donc hier la garde des
sceaux Eric Dupont-Moretti sur
l'épineuse question des revenons
français du Tihad on estime à 1500 le
nombre de français et de Français partis
combattre au sein des rangs de l'État
islamique entre 2012 et 2019 au moment
de la chute de l'État islamique
aujourd'hui d'après le garde des sceaux
il serait encore environ 200 emprisonnés
dans des camps dont des enfants même si
on ignore leur nombre c'est une question
que vous avez posé hier madame Serge
Regnault parce que certains sont nés sur
place et ils n'ont pas d'état civils en
juillet dernier la France a décidé pour
la toute première fois n'aura pas trié
certains avec leur mère ça ne s'était
jamais fait cela concerne 25 enfants et
16 femmes en tout et en début de semaine
une femme et ses deux enfants car l'un
d'entre eux était très malade évidemment
se pose la question de la dangerosité de
ces femmes c'est ce qu'a tenu à
expliquer le garde des sceaux Eric
Dupont aurait dit on écoute
les femmes parties sur jaune sont
traitées comme les hommes contenus de
leur niveau d'endoctrinement et de la
place qui était souvent conférés qu'il
aurait été conféré au sein de daesh
cette exactement ce qui s'est passé en
juillet dernier lors du retour de 16
femmes accompagné de leurs enfants
toutes
ont été mises en examen et incarcéré
dans les établissements susceptibles
d'accueillir les publics terroristes
islamistes femmes
elles seront prises en charge par des
spécialistes de la radicalisation
première question madame sagerino ce
seront des quartiers spéciaux mais
est-ce qu'il y a un rythme de
prosélytisme dans ces prisons d'après
vous
alors d'abord je voudrais dire deux mots
deux mots parce que c'est important pour
moi ce que je dis d'ailleurs au ministre
moi quand je parle de tous ces sujets je
n'oublie pas les centaines de morts et
les blessés que nous avons en France
avec ces gens qui se sont engagés contre
la France et j'ai tenu à le dire au
ministre parce que oui on a un sujet à
traiter sur ces femmes et ses enfants
mais ne jamais oublier qu'elles ont
applaudis les attentats donc ça je pense
que dans la conscience collective il
faudra toujours que faudra jamais
l'oublier sur l'avait rappelé je l'ai
rappelé avant de prendre la parole parce
que je pense que voilà c'est un sujet
compliqué pour lequel tout le monde peut
avoir un avis mais ça il faut pas
l'oublier il y a quand des gens qui sont
allaient combattre la France et la
République ailleurs et qui ont applaudis
quand il y a eu des morts chez nous donc
je pense que on peut avoir on peut
pleurnicher sur Saint-André mais ça
jamais moi je ne l'oublierai alors sur
ces femmes oui c'est ce qui est ce qui
est compliqué c'est savoir comment elle
rentre et il l'a dit le ministre est là
pour le coup je partage ses propos
c'est-à-dire que chacune a une histoire
chacune a une histoire en partant et
chacune a une histoire en revenant et
savoir
ce qu'elle pense vraiment aujourd'hui
c'est extrêmement compliqué et que dès
lors qu'il y a le moindre la moine
interrogation sur le projet de Suisse
elles sont elles sont isolées
aujourd'hui elles sont isolées mais
voilà quid de ce qu'elles sont vraiment
je pense personne peut le dire
aujourd'hui il y a évidemment il y a il
y a des experts qui sont là autour de
ces femmes pour essayer de comprendre ce
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui elles sont
effectivement tout emprisonnées et
heureusement je dirais maintenant on se
posera la question de combien de temps
sont-elles emprisonnées que
deviendront-elles quand elle sortiront
comment seront-elles suivies surveillées
parce que quand même la question se pose
tout comme les hommes qui sortent
aujourd'hui donc voilà c'est un vrai
sujet pour notre pays et notre société
mais on va y revenir d'ailleurs mais il
a eu aussi été question hier des enfants
quand on estime des enfants chaque cas
est examiné au cas par cas car ses
enfants peuvent avoir été endoctrinés
ces scarabée le ministre hier certains
aussi ont été témoins d'atrocité on a
notamment appris lors de l'audition que
11 mineurs ont fait l'objet de
poursuites pénales pour chef
d'associations de malfaiteurs
terroristes autre élément important qui
ressorti de cette audition et qu'on ne
savait pas forcément c'est que c'est le
gouvernement qui décide du retour de ses
enfants ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de
recours possible devant un juge pour des
grands-parents qui voudraient rapatrier
leur petit enfant par exemple en clair
c'est la France qui décide qui est le
rapatrie ça a fait polémique car il y a
quelques années la France a refusé le
retour de deux Françaises et de leurs
enfants estimant que les conditions de
sécurité n'étaient pas réunies ce choix
a été sanctionné par la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme c'était
mi-septembre elle demande qu'il y ait un
contrôle indépendant de ces décisions le
Garde des Sceaux a réagi là dessus
nous n'avons pas attendu cette arrêt
pour agir et 77 enfants sont déjà
rentrés et pris en charge
d'autres retours sont possibles mais il
dépendent directement des conditions de
sécurité sur place les choses sont
difficiles
en cause évidemment la sécurité des
différents intervenants nos soldats bien
sûr
des
déchirements internes parce que la femme
qui accepte de livrer son enfant et
elle-même victime des autres femmes qui
sont restées là puisqu'elle est
considérée comme collabo
l'avocate des familles de ces femmes à
réagi elle a dit que c'est la fin du
fait du prince la fin de l'arbitraire
est-ce que vous trouviez que c'était
trop flou ces conditions de rapatriement
non mais moi si vous voulez les grandes
postures qui dit c'est la fin de
l'arbitraire d'abord il y a des pays qui
refusent de les récupérer déjà les dix
pays qui n'aura pas pris aucune femme
aucun enfant donc la France le fait avec
des conditions qu'elle a défini c'est
normal c'est quand même la France est
quand même libre de décider ce qu'elle
peut faire qu'elle peut pas faire je
vous rappelle que la France a été quand
même le pays le plus le plus attaqué
avec le plus grand nombre de victimes le
terrorisme islamiste donc on a quand
même le droit de protéger les Français
aujourd'hui
moi je suis opposé le retour des femmes
et des hommes qui sont sur zone la
question des enfants elle est compliquée
il y a pas de d'avoir sur les enfants
une comme ça une position très affirmée
elle est compliquée parce qu'il y a
plusieurs sortes d'enfants et les
enfants qui sont partis d'ici et les
enfants qui sont nés là-bas comme vous
l'avez rappelé qu'ils n'ont pas d'état
civil les enfants qui sont nés sur zone
n'ont pas d'état civils quand ils
reviennent il y a les services chargés
de cette question qui sont censés leur
donner à l'état civile et puis il y a
des enfants comme vous l'avez rappelé
qui deviennent ils sont presque majeurs
ils ont 16-17 ans ils ont commis des
choses et vous l'avez rappelé le
ministre a dit bah il y a des procédures
contre eux parce que effectivement ils
ont été endoctrinés donc tout ça fait
que voilà les grandes théories de dire
font rapatrier tout le monde dans
n'importe quelle du condition moi je
pense que la France a le droit de dire
oui ou non et de le faire petit à petit
moi vos juin je le répète moi je suis
opposé au retour des femmes des enfants
ça me pose question parce que Ben toute
façon les laisser dans des camps
humainement je comprends que des
grands-parents souhaitent récupérer
leurs petits-enfants qu'ils ont connu ou
qu'ils n'ont pas connu voilà ça c'est
une vraie question maintenant même pour
les adolescents on peut pas les faire
rapatrier comme ça et en se disant bah
venez tout va bien ces enfants ils sont
traumatisés ils ont été endoctrinés
peut-être qu'ils déteste même le pays
dans lequel ils vont arriver ils
détestent peut-être même leur propre
famille je pense que le travail des psy
et travailleur sociaux ou des éducateurs
et lourd pour parce que chaque enfant a
une histoire en fait vraiment on va y
revenir mais une question sur ce retour
parce que c'est vrai que jusqu'à
maintenant il y avait des retours au cas
par cas plutôt individuel là Audrey la
rappeler en juillet il y a eu un
rapatriement de masse est-ce que ça veut
dire que la France a changé de doctrine
là-dessus est-ce qu'il faut revenir à
une doctrine du cas par cas il a dit que
bon il y avait peut-être les conditions
qui permettaient d'en rapatriser d'un
coup parce que faut quand même savoir
que et voilà moi je suis pas
spécialement quelqu'un qui défend le
gouvernement mais clairement les
conditions géopolitiques sont pas si
simple non plus sur place voilà ils sont
dans des camps certaines on a peur
qu'elle s'échappe et qu'elle retourne
voir leurs copains voilà terroriste donc
les conditions géopolitiques quand même
avoir l'honnêteté d'admettre qu'elles ne
sont pas simples et que nous connaissons
de rapatriement ne sont pas simples avec
celles et ceux qui travaillent sur place
sur ce sujet donc oui là il y a eu un
finement un retour important mais parce
qu'un travail très très lent a dû être
fait avant et voilà donc on verra
aujourd'hui le ministre n'a pas dit
qu'il y en a 15 qui arrivaient demain
pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout il a
dit d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il y aura
d'autres cadeaux prévus oui il sait pas
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas parce que les contextes sont très
particuliers chacun et chacune a une
histoire et que la France ne doit pas se
mettre en danger en rapatrien ces femmes
et ses enfants le rapatriement des
femmes c'est aussi pour pouvoir
rapatrier les enfants mais ce que elles
ne veulent pas forcément donner leurs
enfants oui sauf que rien n'interdit que
les enfants rentrent sur les mers voilà
parce qu'il y a peut-être des mères qui
veulent pas rentrer il y a des enfants
qui sont rentrés sans leur mère ah les
enfants qui sont rentrés aussi sans père
ni mère parce que les deux sont morts
donc ceux-là ont été rapatriés
évidemment peut-être en priorité ça
évidemment les enfants livrer eux-mêmes
dans les camps on peut imaginer que
c'est pas simple mais il y a rien qui
interdit que des enfants puissent
rentrer sans leurrer d'ailleurs il y a
des familles que je connais qui se
disent nous la priori ce sont nos
enfants nos neveux nos filles ou nos
fils qui sont engagées on peut
comprendre que la France est des
réticences allaient retrouver mais sur
les enfants voilà je peux comprendre que
des grands-parents ont envie de les
retrouver sauf que ils ne vont pas
toucher dans leur famille parce que le
contexte doit être aussi bien étudié sur
la capacité des proches à les récupérer
votre collègue Stéphane Le rudellier
hier a évoqué la déchéance de
nationalité pour les adultes c'est
quelque chose que c'est un vrai sujet
moi ça me pose pas de problème qu'on
pose la question de des chances de
nationalité de des gens qui ont combattu
la France à l'extérieur c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser
avant et le sujet serait réglé
quelque chose d'assez intéressant c'est
votre collègue Cécile Karman qui a posé
la question en disant mais comment on
peut savoir que ces femmes finalement
sont des radicalisés puisqu'elles ont
caché leur volonté de partir déjà en
prime abord et le ministre a répondu par
contre c'est pas on ne peut pas savoir à
100% c'est une réalité et la question de
ma collègue Kerman était effectivement
importante je pense que personne
aujourd'hui et on nous voit parce qu'on
a un peu l'expérience de tout ce qui a
été mis en place ici en France même qui
concerne pas dans ces femmes sur la
déradation personne peut dire qu'on est
sur à 100% que ça a fonctionné et tout
dépend le degré d'implication et on voit
bien lors des attentats il y a eu des
petites mains là qui ont participé qui
ont été condamnés mais on sait bien que
cela bon c'était plutôt de la
délinquance devant-lieu qui participait
avec leurs potes à des choses
effrayantes donc cela peut-être que il
n'était pas autant dans le contexte mais
c'est vrai que c'est extrêmement
compliqué de savoir si quelqu'un a
vraiment tourné la page de cet
engagement
mortifère barbare et féroce quand même
est prête à gérer ses revenons sur cette
question de la directicalisation il y a
aussi des des personnes qui vont sortir
là de prison parce qu'elles ont fini de
purger leur père bon comment on assure
le suivi j'avais eu un débat là-dessus
il y a quelques mois sur comment on a
sur ce sujet
et j'étais rapporteur de sexe fait un
projet enfin on avait fait on avait voté
une loi pour suivre ce qui sortait de
prison on se fait retoquer donc c'est
compliqué parce que notre état droit est
adapté aujourd'hui à cette question des
des revenons des radicalisés et c'est
fait qu'on est pas sûr qu'il soit
d'éradicalisé c'est un sujet que nous
devons aborder et que nous ne voulons
pas mettre sous la table parce que alors
ça demande des moyens humains des moyens
financiers une volonté politique mais
pas que vont diabétique la preuve dans
le précédent mandat on avait fait une
loi et ça a été retoqué cette loi donc
c'est un peu oui je pense que il faut
qu'on arrive à écrire des choses pour
être certain mais il faudrait être un
peu sûr de soi de dire qu'on est certain
que tout fonctionne nous on n'est pas
certain
donc on repart sur une loi qu'on se
redonne les moyens et qu'on est de dire
que il y a une vraie fragilité mais
parce que chaque individu
le cerveau dans lequel on ne peut pas
rentrer et la certitude de savoir si
quelqu'un a complètement tourné la page
je pense que personne peut l'affirmer
aujourd'hui
que ces personnes soient jugées en
France dans leur pays d'origine plutôt
qu'elles soient jugée sur place vous
vous le réfutez ah mais moi qu'elle soit
sujet sur place j'ai aucun sujet non
plus alors là moi aucun état d'âme non
mais il faut il faut que ces gens
comprennent si on a pas de garantie sur
la justice locale
d'abord chaque État est libre d'avoir
ces objectifs moi je veux pas juger la
justice d'un autre pays et moi ça m'est
égal non mais moi ça m'est égal je
n'oublie pas ce que nous avons vécu et
je n'oublie pas que nous sommes quand
même aujourd'hui encore dans un pays qui
peut être menacé par des attentats donc
pas d'état d'âme merci Audrey à tout à
l'heure dans le cas pour parler d'un
tout autre sujet avec vous on parlera de
la problématique du loup rien à voir ça
sera le débat du club on va parler d'un
autre sujet puisque vous avez posé une
question d'actualité au Gouvernement sur
la question du voile et des atteintes à
la laïcité est-ce que vous avez été la
fête de la réponse que vous a fait le
gouvernement pas du tout mais je
m'attendais pas à grand chose d'ailleurs
pas du tout alors d'abord je pensais que
c'était monsieur Darmanin qui allait
répondre c'était pas monsieur Damana
c'est pour lequel j'ai beaucoup de
respect et d'amitié mais la réponse elle
a été totalement décalée
osé dire que on attendait des chiffres
alors que tout le monde constate depuis
2 ans et depuis la rentrée et l'année
dernière scolaire qu'on a livrés sujets
dans les écoles et les lycées dire qu'on
attend des chiffres on n'a pas besoin
des chiffres on a des enfants on a des
enseignants aujourd'hui des armées parce
qu'il y a pas de ligne
la mise l'éducation nationale a osé dire
que quand les équipes pédagogiques
étaient formées bien non tout ça se
réglait avec du bon sens mais c'est
hallucinant c'est pour ça que je me suis
autorisé de dire ça c'est un ministre
d'éducation nationale en gros qui dit
aux enseignants débrouillez-vous chacun
d'un modifier non c'est pas comme ça
qu'on gère la France il y a une ligne et
la ligne elle est pas écrite donc
évidemment que la réponse de la
secrétaire d'État était totalement
décalé et qu'elle n'a apporté aucune
réponse mais je à un moment j'ai rappelé
au gouvernement que le courage était une
obligation en politique et que les
ennemis fallait savoir les nommer et il
fallait savoir les combattre et
aujourd'hui moi je suis très inquiet de
ce qui se passe dans les écoles et dans
les collèges parce que cette espèce de
pensée islamique qui se diffuse dans le
pays bah elle arrive dans les écoles et
là c'est très très grave donc le truc on
attend des chiffres on attend machin et
on va se concerter ça suffit une réponse
ferme vous n'y croyez pas bon ben
j'attends j'attends la réponse à ce que
la semaine dernière il a pas eu de
réponse ferme il a dit que les équipes
pédagogiques avec du bon sens elle est
réglé le problème mais c'est mais c'est
hallucinant quoi donc voilà je pense que
les équipes pédagogiques elles attendent
que le ministre leur disent stop stop il
y a même hier la ministre qui a dit on
fait une différence si quelqu'un arrive
une fois au lycée comme ça aussi bien
tous les jours mais comment on peut
oser dire ça mais c'est c'est juste
hallucinant et évidemment tous nos
ennemis de la République quand ils
entendent des discours aussi mous aussi
inutiles bah il rentre dans nos
tolérance notre faiblesse et voilà nous
en sommes aujourd'hui voilà et l'école
de la République elle doit être protégée
là qu'on se construit au-delà de nos
différences de nos couleurs de peau de
notre origine sociale l'école de la
République c'est le socle de la
construction des enfants de ce pays donc
stop près de temps qu'il y a une note
des services de l'État qui a tiré la
sonnette il y a quelques semaines le
sujet de pose sur les réseaux sociaux
qui appelait à transgresser la loi sur
l'interdiction des signes religieux tout
le monde y va il y a pas de limite il y
a pas de discours mais là-dessus
qu'est-ce que vous attendez précisément
du gouvernement mais moi j'attends un
discours clair vous savez on a vécu le
gouvernement précédent qui à peu près le
même qu'aujourd'hui dans la loi
séparatisme quand monsieur Darmanin
m'avait dit Madame essayatrice tout vous
amendements textile ça c'est hors de
question ben voilà on en est avec les
amendements textiles qu'on a pas voulu
prendre donc voilà assumons mais
arrêtons de laisser cette pensée vous
savez vous savez très sincèrement c'est
un sujet sur le carrelage je travaille
beaucoup les Frères musulmans dans ce
pays travaillent depuis longtemps et
aujourd'hui sont arrivés à un point il
va falloir leur dire STOP vraiment un
mot sur le combat des familles
iraniennes puisqu'il y avait un débat
hier au Sénat au même moment de votre
audition Derrick Dupont que vous inspire
ce combat des femmes iraniennes ou
d'abord évidemment ils ont tout mon
soutien vous l'imaginez mais quel
courage quel courage et c'est pour ça
que dans mon ma prise de parole hier
j'ai parlé des deux en disant elles ont
le courage et admettez que elle on a les
mots là les mots là quand même en Iran
qui sont capables de tuer des femmes
uniquement parce qu'elle veut pas poser
au vol et après on me dit que le voile
n'est pas un étendard politique ou
religieux bah ça ça prouve tous les
jours que c'en est un parce
qu'aujourd'hui les femmes et les hommes
qui combattent le système patriarcal et
ce pouvoir théocratique en Iran c'est
parce qu'elle ne veut pas le mettre le
voile au départ alors il y a peut-être
autre chose il y a peut-être une
revendications une soif de liberté enfin
c'est ça le symbole il est là donc en
France ouvrons les yeux et arrêtons de
dire que ce n'est pas un symbole que le
voile n'est pas un étendard politique
interdiction du vol en France il faut
l'interdire dans tout l'espace public
moi personnellement ça me gênerait pas
qu'on le fasse mais on sait que c'est
pas possible mais
il faut qu'on soit beaucoup plus clair
sur ce compte tolère un peu partout
vraiment donc moins de tolérance c'est à
dire faut pas changer la loi mais moins
de tolérance
de l'actualité dans nos régions on va
aller du côté de Grenoble retrouver
Stéphane Blaisy bonjour Stéphane merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos journalistes au
service police justice du Dauphiné
Libéré et Stéphane l'actualité chez vous
vous revenez sur ce refus d'obtempérer
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi à
Grenoble une femme de 18 ans passagère
d'un du véhicule est morte que s'est-il
passé
alors ce qui est intéressant de savoir
d'abord c'est que la fusillade qui s'est
déroulé dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi
elle intervient après une première
fusillade qui n'a aucun lien qui s'est
déroulé il y a moins de quatre jours
dans laquelle un homme a été blessé par
la police dans une après une poursuite
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi tout
est parti d'un revenu c'est un
automobiliste qui a refusé un contrôle
de police dans un quartier de la
banlieue de Grenoble et le le l'homme a
pris la fuite la police l'a pris en
chasse cette poursuite s'est déroulée
dans les rues de Grenoble non loin du
centre et de la gare l'homme a très vite
tiré des coups de feu en direction de la
police au cours de la poursuite il s'est
retrouvé coincé dans une rue les
policiers étaient descendus de leur
voiture et l'homme leur a foncé dessus
ils ont ils ont fait feu à ce moment-là
sur sur la voiture du fuyard et
lorsqu'ils ont interpellé au sud de la
ville au terme de la poursuite les
policiers ont découvert que dans la
voiture se trouvait une jeune femme de
18 ans qui avait été touchée par balle
au niveau du cou et qui était qui est
décédé quelques minutes plus tard donc
une véritable tragédie pour
cette jeune fille
dont on ne connaît pas encore le lien
avec le conducteur de la voiture le lien
exact quant au conducteur de la voiture
on sait que c'est un personnage très
défend défavorablement connu de de la
justice qui a déjà été condamné pour
avoir ouvert le feu sur des sur des
policiers je crois que c'était en 2013
et tout ça se déroule dans un contexte
grenoblois
qui est très très exposé à la violence
pour une raison
assez simple c'est que il y a un trafic
de stupéfiant très important à Grenoble
une économie parallèle qui est
équivalente enfin conséquence de ce
trafic est évidemment
les conflits entre bande rivales alors
même si même si l'affaire de de la nuit
de mardi à mercredi n'est pas
directement a priori lié ce trafic
grenoblois parce que le suspect qui a
été interpellé et plutôt de la région du
Vaucluse cela dit on peut toujours se
demander ce qui faisait ce jour-là à
Grenoble
voilà donc le contexte est Stéphane vous
avez une question pour Jacqueline
messagerie
oui alors si on considère ce cette
ambiance d'économie parallèle et de
trafic très important Grenoble c'est une
situation un peu particulière en France
ou en fait ça existe ailleurs on peut se
demander si la représentation nationale
a pas parfois
l'impression de vider un peu l'océan
avec une petite cuillère en terme de
lutte contre les stupéfiants quelle
réflexion vous pouvez mener pour essayer
de lutter contre ce phénomène de trafic
de stupe alors qu'on s'aperçoit que
depuis des années
c'est une guerre qui qui ne trouve pas
de victoire du côté de des pouvoirs
publics
alors le comptage général du trafic de
drogue vous l'avez rappelé et
effectivement cette économie parallèle
c'est que cette économie qui dans les
cités apportent beaucoup d'argent à
beaucoup de jeunes en particulier et
elle a eu quand même une elle a une
histoire un peu particulière ce qui nous
interroge aujourd'hui c'est en tout cas
moi je suis une élu de banlieue donc
j'ai vu les choses aussi évoluer c'est
qu'on a aujourd'hui
toute une toute une population de
mineurs qui a été intégrée dans le
trafic de drogue ça je voulais le dire
parce que c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'avait pas avant avant on avait des
trafiquants qui avaient au minimum 18 20
ans aujourd'hui dans le trafic de drogue
il y a donc de 13-14 ans ça c'est
quelque chose de très récent voilà après
sur le trafic de drogue clairement
d'abord on peut pas on peut pas baisser
les bras et ne pas lutter contre le
trafic de drogue clairement voilà ça
c'est alors évidemment ce qui s'est
passé dont les événements dont vous nous
avez parlé moi c'est dramatique que sa
jeune fille soit décédée bien sûr
personne ne peut se dire bravo sauf que
le départ de l'histoire ça a refus
d'intempéries d'un voyou qui devrait
être pu être là parce que posons-nous la
question ce type il était quand même
recherché par la police depuis le mois
d'avril depuis le mois d'avril parce
qu'effectivement il a été condamné sur
des faits dont vous ce que vous avez
rappelé mais il a fait d'autres choses
depuis la sortie de prison donc c'est
intime qu'on cherche depuis le mois
d'avril et qui était sous au qtf je le
rappelle c'est que ce type-là devrait ne
devait pas nous voilà une obligation à
quitter le territoire on sait qu'elles
sont très peu appliquées mais enfin le
contexte est là donc plutôt bien
globalement il est là parce que ça
génère tout ça aussi donc du coup c'est
un vrai sujet après après c'est le
trafic de drogue posons-nous la question
d'où vient la drogue on sait quand même
alors je sais que ça fait pas toujours
plaisir quand je dis ça que le Maroc est
quand même un pays qui envahit l'Europe
avec de la drogue bon c'est une réalité
donc voilà donc il faut aussi travailler
sur tout ça sur ce ces relations
internationales que vous nous pouvons
avoir et puis on ne peut pas dire bah
tant pis on laisse faire parce que
derrière non il faut lutter contre les
trafiquants de drogue c'est et puis
parce que je voudrais dire quelque chose
quand même on parle de ce que fait la
police et c'est bien on parle de la
lutte mais moi il y a quelque chose un
volet que je trouve complètement
inexistant dans le pays c'est le volet
santé personne ne dit que quand même ce
que consomme un certain nombre de
personnes dans ce pays c'est carrément
du poisson au sens intellectuel du terme
et il y a pas de politique de prévention
de santé là-dessus on va jamais quelque
chose qui dit c'est quand même pas bon
pour la santé ce que vous fumez ce que
vous consommez parce que il y a quand
même beaucoup de ce que les pétards que
aujourd'hui certains comme ça c'est pas
ce qu'il y avait les années 70
il y a la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui sera
examiné par Tiana la semaine prochaine
les sénateurs LR veulent durcir les
sanctions contre les refus d'obtempérer
ça veut dire que le gouvernement fait
passer pour vous aujourd'hui il faut il
faut durcir les sanctions comme à
proposer ça sur les Rodeo sur les
reflets enfin stop quoi stop et
rappelons tout le temps que quand ça se
man sur un revenu dans Paris et qui a
malheureusement des morts c'est parce
que moi je sais pas vous et moi la
police vous allez arrêter vos contrôles
vous arrêtez bah voilà enfin il faut pas
transformer les choses un revenu
intempéries on en assume les
conséquences voilà merci on va remercier
Stéphane merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous la Une de du Dauphiné course
poursuite et fusillade mortel à Grenoble
c'est à la Une de votre journal
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin dans
[Musique]